ils ont connu la folie des cuisines des
grands restaurants dans les
centres-villes mais la peine de la terre
résonne tellement fort que des chefs
repensent leur métier
comme tous les jours Dominique nourrit
ses poules avec le compost de sa cuisine
une routine bien loin de celle qu'il
avait quand il travaillait dans les
grands restaurants montréalais
[Musique]
les œufs de poules de Dominique
serviront à préparer les desserts du
jour un semi Fredo aux argousiers et une
crème anglaise au petit fruit de la
ferme à la table c'est ce que le chef de
mini-clabel souhaitait pour sa nouvelle
proposition gastronomique parcelle sur
une tombe champagne c'est des gens qui
viennent manger dans un potager puis il
se trouve que le potager il est sur un
terrain comme magnifique justement ça
faisait partie de la réflexion où on
faisait des légumes ici puis on se
disait on est capable de cuisiner on est
capable de choisir des bons vins puis on
a un lieu exceptionnel alors pourquoi
pas enfin profiter les gentils
Dominique devenue agriculteur après un
retour à l'école croyant abandonner son
premier métier de chef les légumes à 14
resto à Montréal tous les mercredis plus
je devais mes beaux petits légumes puis
j'avais tellement d'idées la graine à
germer dans ma tête tranquillement à
force d'avoir des beaux légumes de me
dire que j'étais capable de les
transformer
un potager au bord du lac même
fremagogue qui offre toutes sortes de
légumes toujours les variétés les plus
intéressantes chez les moins communes
pour justement les clients puissent
vivre aussi une expérience côté de
légumes
c'est un oignon vert japonais qu'on fait
pousser super gros pour qu'il soit
vraiment agréable à faire griller c'est
vraiment un oignon qui est plus sucré
plus savoureux qui tient la cuisson
le mouvement forme tout est beau de la
ferme à la table est né en Californie au
début des années 70 avec la chef Alice
Waters et son restaurant Chez Panis elle
a inspiré de nombreux chefs et
restaurants dont le célèbre bluewheel
dans l'État de New York
plus proche de chez nous le mouvement
fait aussi des adeptes après l'étape
champêtre populaire dans les années 80
ou des producteurs cuisinés leurs
produits ce sont désormais les chefs qui
cultivent et apprêtent leur école Martin
Picard du pied de cochon a été l'un des
précurseurs de ce mouvement au Québec
et d'autres ont suivi parmi lesquels la
chef fissionnaire Cannes et son
restaurant Bica en montée régie la
maison bois en Estrie la bergerie la
vieille ferme au Saguenay Lac Saint-Jean
ou encore les faux bergers dans
Charlevoix et selon Dominique c'est un
mouvement qui va prendre de l'ampleur
plusieurs fois par mois on se fait
écrire comme comment vous avez fait
c'est quoi légalement les enjeux c'est
quoi les méthodes d'organisation toutes
les petits détails auxquels on pense pas
mais auquel tu penses quand tu te mets à
vouloir faire un truc comme ça ça va
cadrer ça qui plaît dans les prochaines
années
prépare comme plusieurs personnes ici un
fichier une chips ça va être servi avec
une sauce starter classique et des
pommes de terre style cantine un peu
couper n'importe où après un passage
remarqué à l'émission Les Chefs Chloé
Ouellet a Élodie d'installer son
restaurant loin de la ville
peu importe où est-ce que je vais être
je vais faire ce que j'ai envie de faire
découvrir un restaurant gastronomique
dans un village de 800 habitants c'est
un peu bête mais finalement c'est une
super bonne idée elle sait donner une
mission sortir les gens de la ville pour
qu'ils viennent à la campagne d'éduquer
un peu les gens que la gastronomie ça
peut se faire ailleurs c'est comme ça
qui est né au pâturage dans le petit
village de sainte Perpétue au centre du
Québec avec son associé Maude à Grenoble
de formation elle produisent la
quasi-totalité des légumes qu'elles
servent au restaurant on essaie de pas
rester dans ce qui est traditionnelle
entre autres dans les aubergines on est
allé vraiment chercher il y a des
variétés un petit peu plus rares comme
par exemple la malarossa qui est une
aubergine
on s'est permis un petit peu de folie on
a essayé d'incorporer le plus possible
de Flore et de vivaces comestible
c'est magnifique en fait on a de la
menthe mais c'est de la menthe pouliotte
donc qui va être quand même plus fine
plus floral un petit peu si on a des
petits freinsiers alpin en fait qu'on a
même parti en graine Yoda ça plusieurs
mois donc c'est des petites phrases
blanches ça on fait quoi avec ça chef ça
en fait je pense qu'on est dégueulasse
juste comme ça ça rapporte toute sa
valeur
c'est ou sur un petit dessert mais pas
trop la travailler
[Musique]
si j'ai ici je veux vivre quel sorte
d'expérience en fait ici toutes les
semaines c'est un 5 à 7 services menus
dégustation fixe les gens ont aucun
choix ils viennent manger une autre
cuisine avec des produits hyper locaux
ou non produits d'ici et c'est pour
Chloé le local va jusqu'en Gaspésie
c'est pour mettre de l'avant les
produits du Saint-Laurent sur la table
du restaurant on retrouve des trucs très
poussés un peu travailler tout ce qu'on
voit un peu moins qui est en train
d'émerger au Québec côté poisson fruit
de masse pas mal ceux que nous on a
envie de servir ici en fait l'oursin de
la MAC très bas c'est en train de
revenir on sort beaucoup de loups marins
et quand on mange à la table de Chloé on
n'est jamais bien loin du producteur
voisin on a une ferme de wapiti au
village le roi du Cher qui est à 2 km on
va chercher des lapins pas trop loin
nous ce qu'on fait à toutes les semaines
on a un producteur affilié puis on
invite le producteur à souper c'est là
qu'on développe un peu une petite
communauté les gens sont tellement fiers
de parler de leurs produits les clients
autour on leur dit ah c'est eux qui
produisent l'agneau que vous mangez ce
soir ça crée tellement un beau lien
super
c'est quoi
ça a l'air bon
de tournesol huile de tournesol bio il y
a une crème fraîche aux tomates
fermentée et aïoli au basilic les
crudités c'est rabiol japonaise et
rosaki Chourave concombre
et les pizzas de Dominique viennent
compléter le menu
au final nos chefs sont-ils des
cuisiniers ou des agriculteurs c'est
amplement deux métiers bien différents
qui finissent par se compléter c'est
complètement différent en même temps
absolument liés
du mois d'août en janvier quand je fais
mon plan de culture c'est un peu sûr
[Musique]
une toute autre expérience bon appétit
je pense que le consommateur aussi c'est
ce qu'il veut vivre vivre des
expériences un peu partout se promener
sortir de la ville
on laisse les gens aller ils peuvent
déplacer les tables c'est pique-niques
dans les champs dans les jardins où
poussent les légumes on donne la
nourriture puis on s'occupe pas deux une
fois qu'on a commandé là c'est juste
l'atmosphère fait et tellement différent
de celle d'un restaurant normal que ça
change complètement les rapports qu'on a
fait autant on fait pas de service au
temple au temps on a des discussions je
pense qu'ils sont complètement
différentes de celles d'un restaurant
habituel le temps c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on a c'est quelque
[Musique]